fallout 4 still has plenty of DLC on the  way and next on the list is far harbor  and now we know when it's coming I'm  Tony and this game spot news update  comes straight from the Commonwealth the  new DLC hits ps4 xbox one and pc on  Thursday May nineteenth this expansion  sends you on a new case for the  valentine detective agency to the island  of far harbor a post-apocalyptic version  of Maine's Bar Harbor the island is the  largest landmass Bethesda has ever  developed for a DLC pack it'll be filled  with new quests high-level weapons and  armor and lethal enemies far Harbor will  cost you 25 bucks by itself but it's  included in fallout 4 is fifty dollar  season pass picking that up will also  get you the previously released ultimate  Ron and wasteland workshop DLC packs  plus all the upcoming expansions maybe  we'll hear more about that unannounced  DLC 83 for now you can keep it locked at  gamespot for all the fallout news you  need